[Music]
our relentless stampede towards wealth
and comfort has cracked open our earth
can you feel her sagging and groaning
under the weight of our greed ecosystem
severed barren and bleeding but all hail
progress right
we have bruised and abused and depleted
our land given warning after warning we
bide our time knowledge is no longer the
great barrier it once was
earth is shedding her familiar skin
and this home will no longer welcome we
who have squandered our humanity on
progress
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we no longer have luxury attending
tomorrow waiting for someone somewhere
to do something gorging on articles
reports and statements acting a message
taking in more information will change
our faith the truth is laid out in broad
scorching daylight written in oil and
blood and ash co-signed by the cries of
ancient wisdom we did this we've run out
of time it consequences
[Music]
but before you drown in the sea of
pointed fingers before you aim your
fists in blame mix up your hand and say
yes to the future that is now hard to
construct despair is not an option our
ancestors have not survived the
catastrophes of war famine and
enslavement just so that our fragile
spines could not even break the glass on
our screens stop screaming into your
boxes and
[Music]
we must press forward hope is the only
option is hope is the only option is
hope is the only option is hope is the
only option is to not opt out we will
not opt out we will not be enslaved by
our desire for power our desperation for
power our dependence on power but can we
regenerate this world with our power our
wealth our knowledge our no holds the
power to change we can't just stop this
train of progress we must reroute we
must heal the damage we must
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
but the one thing we need more than hope
is action once we start to act hope is
everywhere so instead of looking for
hope
look for action then and only then hope
will come
you